covet emergency in China the people of
China are stuck in a nightmare China's
zero covert approach seems to be
backfiring badly which is oddly Dawning
uglier and playing on repeat public
anger and rare Street protests led to
many rules being relaxed 900 million
Chinese have contracted the virus since
2020. hospitals are overflowing with
coronavirus cases now that the country's
abandoned its strict zero covert
policies media calls this a pandemic
tsunami concerns are growing over a
potential surge of cases in rural areas
as people set out to travel for the
Lunar New Year holidays some health
experts predict China could suffer up to
a million coveted deaths in the next few
months and this outbreak could also
threaten the global economy China is
indeed in a weak spot what isn't China
telling the world about what's really
happening
foreign
[Music]
covet is exploding in China again right
now and it came back with a vengeance so
brace yourselves ladies and gentlemen
because here we go again
[Music]
the hospital is just overwhelmed from
top to bottom so you know the ER filled
up with people a lot of them got
admitted to the hospital they're not
getting better in a day or two so
there's no flow so they're stopped under
ayodar and the Chinese government is
working really hard to cover this up
Beijing is facing its worst covet
outbreak after the government eased
strict containment measures nearly two
weeks ago what's surprising is the
government isn't reporting many deaths
yet at the same time the death business
seems to be surging several shop-selling
funeral supplies some told me that
business has gone up threefold and
prices have doubled yet some say they're
stuck with stock that they can sell
because people are not able to hold
funerals Let Me Now read out what the
who is emergencies director recently
said I'm courting we believe that the
current number is being published from
China underrepresents the true impact of
the disease are you kidding me on
December 20th 2022 the Chinese
government were put at 3 1049 covet
infections but according to an Insider
government official that number was
actually closer to 37 million Beijing is
not reporting China's true death toll
from this latest wave all right covet
zero a distant memory in China is nearly
37 million people may have been infected
in one day this week the Chinese
government said that they have about
fewer than 5 000 cases per day although
precise numbers are very difficult to
come by the official Chinese numbers
don't look anywhere near as dire as what
is generally being understood and
establishing how big this outbreak is
isn't easy official statistics note 16
covered deaths in the last month but
there's skepticism about these figures
then look at the far right of this chart
the number of confirmed cases is falling
but that's because Mass testing in China
stopped recently which means no one's
quite sure what's happening with the
virus the Chinese people have been under
brutal coveted lockdowns for more than
three years now but in in late November
2022 they have finally had enough and
mass protests broke out
[Music]
so by December 8th president Xi Jinping
actually gave in and he actually dropped
all the covet restrictions he had given
the people exactly what they wanted
Freedom the opportunity to travel no
more lockdowns this morning for the
first time since the start of the
pandemic Travelers are streaming into
China arriving reuniting but
unfortunately president XI didn't take
one crucial thing into account China has
since it's been now well over a month a
substantial wave and a population that
we know generally speaking was
relatively under vaccinated no one has
natural immunity but we also know that
they're domestically generated vaccines
aren't great in most of the countries
that used them in order to get their
kind of first batch then moved on to a
western model that worked better so they
had a two-fold problem they did not have
vaccines and they didn't develop natural
immunity and now everyone's getting hit
all at once with a virus that has at
least 50 percent more communicability
than the measles see unlike the rest of
the world China's brutal lockdown
announcement they were not given the
chance to build their immunity
[Music]
and instead of easing back on lockdowns
gradually like other countries did she
opened the floodgates overnight the
Chinese are about to embark on some 2
billion trips this Lunar New Year some
or possibly many of them will be
carrying the coronavirus with them
remember this is the event that sparked
the first mass spreading of covid-19
from Wuhan so now unsurprisingly covet
is going crazy again over there
[Music]
foreign
manner in which it was abandoned I mean
speaks to a chronic governance failure a
lot of these local governments are
highly indebted they've got big cash
flow problems this is a big problem that
the central government and local
governments will have to sort out a new
variants might be forming there are
seven different variants circulated in
Beijing right now or in China right now
three of them did not exist two or three
months ago and it takes about six months
of data for you to get good information
on the r naught and The lethality so we
just don't know and then third in part
because of she when you're a one-man
State all policy and all authority
starts and stops with you and unless
you're providing very clear guidance on
everything which is impossible for one
person to do for a whole country
especially when the size of China the
bureaucracy either goes into automatic
or does nothing well right now it's
doing nothing so the data decisions in
China are not to gather data figure out
what we can do it's to instead of
gathering data and lying about it we're
just not going to gather any data at all
so we're not going to know how bad these
strains are until they get out of China
and circulate in the rest of the world
for six months so the lowest fatality
estimate that I have seen that I
consider credible is that they're going
to lose a million and a half people just
from covet so stay danger subscribe for
more and welcome to another episode of
the gift that keeps on giving coven
this was done in a sort of convulsive
political Lurch people were not prepared
for it so many hospitals are completely
under strained medical staff under
immense pressure crematoriums are
working overtime and now it looks like
it's going to get even worse
if you happen to run a business where
you ship your products to your customers
you know how much of a headache it's
been with China and all the supply chain
issues but you know what will make your
life a lot easier ship station
shipstation is hands down the best way
to ship if you're running an e-commerce
business with shipstation you'll be able
to ship with confidence knowing that
you're saving up to 88 off from Top
carriers like UPS USPS and DHL Express
it's no wonder why over 130 000
Merchants use shipstation and why 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year end up using it for life here's how
it works simply import your orders from
almost every selling channel that you
can think of Shopify Amazon Etsy and
more then you can use their scam-based
workflows bulk updates and automation
processes to ship your orders super fast
while you're shipping faster than ever
before you're going to be accessing
shipping discounts of up to 84 you'll be
able to compare rates from Top carriers
and you'll be able to print labels
individually or in batches shipstation
will even instantly update the tracking
information to the selling Channel and
the customer wants to order ships so go
into the new year with totally
stress-free affordable shipping by going
to shipstation.com for a 60-day free
trial that's two months of Cheaper
simpler shipping completely for free go
to shipstation.com with the link below
right now thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
third twenty twenty
Xi Jinping invokes his zero covet policy
a policy that over the next three years
will destroy the spirit of the Chinese
people to deal with the spread China
implemented a zero covet policy under
zero covid no measure was too drastic to
get official case counts to zero
foreign
he literally meant Zero if you were in a
store and a covet case was detected you
would have to quarantine literally right
then and there in the store and sleep
there overnights
[Music]
if you were on a flight and a passenger
tested positive for coven you might get
sent to a quarantine Camp upon Landing
foreign
if you went to a protest that the
government wanted to shut down they
could simply turn your health codes red
and send you home
once you got back home you would be
locked in by the order of the
governments
[Applause]
might even weld your door shut
there was literally no way out no
escaping it
after three long years of this the
Chinese people finally pulled down their
mass and fought back they demanded that
this insane zero covet policy be dropped
and after weeks of raising hell the
Chinese government did actually seem to
listen to the masses and Xi Jinping did
actually drop the restrictions we start
with an update China is scrapping some
of its most controversial coveted rules
moving away from their strict zero covet
policy a lot of that was probably
because the protest did actually
threaten China's bottom line especially
with the protest at the iPhone Factory
in China watch our video on that by
clicking the card on the top right
corner of the screen so for a brief
moment the Chinese people thought they
had actually won they thought that this
was really the end when in reality
things were about to get much much worse
[Music]
covid cases are skyrocketing quite
possible that there'll be a million
deaths or more this winter from covert
in in China emergency rooms are packed
funeral homes are overflooded incredibly
and
a time for many of these people some of
them have lost loved ones and are unable
to find spaces in the crematorium
and those who can't even get a spot at
the crematorium are resorting to using
their own backyards and the Chinese
government has been trying their best to
cover this up to keep the masses from
panicking but then a bunch of Chinese
celebrities from entrepreneurs to
academics to opera singers all started
dying from covet so now the masses are
starting to learn the truth see when you
lock up the largest population in the
world for three years and then suddenly
let them out of their cages they will
get sick it's like a kid catching
chickenpox for the first time there is
an extremely rapid rise of covid-19
cases in China the infections are
primarily being fueled by the Omicron
variants now here's what has experts
concern right every new infection in
China provides an opportunity for the
coronavirus to change there's limited
immunity amongst China's large
population of 1.4 billion and and even
though fact vaccination rates overall
High the number of folks getting booster
shots is much lower especially amongst
the elderly also China's vaccines have
proven to be less effective against
severe infection than our messenger RNA
versions here in the U.S plus most
vaccines were given more than a year ago
so the effectiveness has decreased all
of this you know creates the perfect
scenario for the virus to change the
more a virus spreads the more likely it
will produce a new variance uh yes we do
see when the virus spreads to lots more
people that you get more variants
because the more it reproduces the
higher the chance of a mutation or a
recombination event and that's actually
what's really concerning about China
China is now an incubator and 1.4
billion people with low immunity is The
Perfect Storm
[Music]
foreign
so what about the rest of the world
while China stayed inside and weakened
their immune system we made ours
stronger with some caveats mRNA vaccines
only last for six months according to
Yale medicine natural immunity only
lasts one year and governments have
gotten real comfortable with lockdowns
and now that China might be brewing in
new variants the world is blocking them
out countries like Italy Spain France
have said that they'll perhaps have some
form of testing perhaps proof of a
negative covert test before arrival or
proof of vaccination countries are
putting up travel restrictions on
Chinese citizens the U.S Canada India
Australia France and the UK are all
demanding negative tests at their
borders Morocco and South Korea have
banned Chinese Travelers altogether and
the reason why all these countries are
putting up their barricades is because
Xi Jinping is not sharing any
information go to the website of China's
national Health commission and you will
see a list of daily covet case reports
dating all the way back to February 2020
daily reports that they just randomly
stopped doing on December 24 2022 right
when things were getting out of hand
again wow how convenient right raise
your hand if that sounds fishy so what
is the Chinese government trying to hide
right now are they trying to hide how 90
I repeat 90 of China's third largest
province has been infected with coven or
how 18 of China's population got
infected during the month of December
alone whatever the Chinese government is
trying to hide it is not working a lot
of countries are still closing their
borders with China but not all of them
see some countries are too poor too
corrupt too dependent on Chinese tourism
to close our borders with China some
countries are happy that China finally
opened up their borders they don't care
about the welfare of their population so
in those countries covet will spread
faster than others all we can do is hope
that things won't link to the rest of
the world again
one of the things the West has been
trying to force China and other
countries like India to do is to get
them to stop using coal why because coal
contributes to climate change too much
what do you want to do leave a Barren
Wasteland for our children's children to
inherit have a heart the problem is
countries like China and India run on
coal they can't afford to switch over to
renewable energy stopping the use of
coalwood grind their economies to a halt
and make them powerless on top of that
rich Western countries would have never
gotten so rich and Powerful if it wasn't
for them using coal if it wasn't for
them spewing out a ton of emissions and
yet the West is trying to do everything
in their power to not let China and
India get rich in the same manner as
they did and the West isn't willing to
pay for it either the United States four
or five percent of the world's
population still uses 25 percent of the
world's resources you Outsource
production to China and then you say
China is the carbon polluter China is
producing your buckets China is
producing a nuts and bolts China is
producing your phones try to produce it
in your own countries and see your
carbon emissions rise you love lecturing
us because you have a colonial mentality
then there are Colonial structures and
institutions you lend us money and every
time you lend us money which is our
money which is our money every time the
international monetary fund comes to our
societies and they tell us here's the
money we are giving you we are giving
you no it's our money you give us our
money back as debt and then you lecture
us about how we should live it's
extraordinary it's not just the colonial
mentality it's the colonial structures
and institutions which reproduce
themselves year after year after year
and let me tell you something the
climate Justice movement not include in
the in enough on this not glued enough
on this the climate Justice movement is
a movement that says we're worried about
our future what future what future
children in the African continent in
Asia in Latin America they don't have a
future they don't have a present we are
not worried about the future they're
worried about their present your slogan
is we're worried about the future
what future that's a middle class
Bourgeois Western slogan you've got to
be worried about now
2.7 billion people can't eat now and
you're telling people reduce your
consumption how does this sound to a
child who hasn't eaten in days it's
almost like the West uses climate change
as a way to keep poor countries poor to
keep the slave slaves now we're not
saying climate change isn't real or
anything as for the YouTube Community
guidelines we're just saying that
climate change is an awfully convenient
excuse to keep poor countries poorer
wouldn't you say so and we break it all
down in our latest private documentary
on climate change watch it right now by
clicking the card on the screen
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]